yes when I came there was a name an
Institute for Research on women and
gender but it really hadn't been very
active and so one of the reasons I was
hired was to make it active and in the
early years it was they want problems so
when they were problems in they were
there's our structural and bureaucratic
rather than political right how do you
produce a gender studies program that
isn't isolated from the rest of the
intellectual life of the University that
of course keeps its political edge
because Gender Studies almost by
definition are about gender difference
in gender hockey and the way gender
difference is translated into hierarchy
but on the other hand are it's really
dependent on in part of the intellectual
agendas of many many many disciplines I
would say all disciplines although
there's some we haven't penetrated so
the problem was figuring out how to
accommodate the needs of food apartments
and at the same time to produce a
curriculum that allowed some students to
make gender studies in the center of
their work but also to have the power of
the methodologies of the disciplines of
a discipline typically and then
conversely to have the students who are
focusing on sociology or literature or
something like that the particular
insights that can come from looking at
the world as a gendered place so that
those were the problems one of the other
problems was Barnard already had a real
woman Studies program and we were
dependent on it and worked in
cooperation with it but the Barnett
curriculum is very different from the
coffee college to work in curriculum and
so there were a lot of just bureaucratic
and structural problems in figuring out
okay how do you make gender studies
available to Columbia student who will
have done all the core which takes a lot
of time but also prepares them in
certain ways to do certain kinds of work
that you can't assume a bar nerd student
has done and I think probably our
department maybe more than any others
confronted the problem of the difference
in the two curriculums in a way that
coming up almost no in the department
does it was all worked out but it took a
lot of work the interesting thing was
that the other problem that faced me
when I got here was there was no Black
Studies program there was no ethnic
studies program there was no sir there
was no program in queer studies and so
all of the demand for that kind of
education tended to land on the gender
studies department we in fact had some
curriculum development programs funded
with outside money that we're supposed
to be about both race and gender because
it was the only place to get grace
seriously taking account or ethnic
studies
another problem we had was the you know
sexuality and gay studies or queer
studies one of the things that has kind
of plague women's studies right from the
beginning was that women were equated
with sex so that if you wanted to study
the history of sex or you know sexual
practices sexual orientation it went to
women's studies and those were all
pretty big agendas for one place to
manage but we try and it caused some
tension in the feminist community
because then you know what we could do
on two straight women studies was more
limited because we're trying to do these
other things and also because you
certainly I and allow my colleagues in
and the expertise now over time what's
happened is of course we've built
vigorous African American Studies
program and there's ethnic studies
around which there's still a lot of
tension about how that should be
structured but there's more and more
courses etc and at least a program we
don't have a
Center for the Study of sexuality or
anything but the literature has expanded
so much and the other thing that's
happened over the 20 years that I've
been at Columbia is that the faculty
with expertise in these areas is just
expanded like mad so there's no longer
just one person we supposed to know all
these things